hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the whisper challenge
made up by a mr. Joe Suggs I'm here with
Mathias Wade and Tyler they can't hear
anything
hi sorry to interrupt but I explained
this miserably the whisper challenge
were the other three participants are
listening to very loud music and can't
hear what I'm saying so I read the tweet
and then whisper it very quietly to them
they try to read my lips and interpret
what I'm saying and then pass that along
to the next person like a game of
telephone
obviously hilarity ensues afterwards
okay
markiplier is a gorgeous man do it again
that's not part of the challenge yes oh
I can only hear you if you're yelling so
Jeff whisper what your have no idea
what's happening shut up boy markiplier
is a gorgeous man okay alright and we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna rotate
Hilter kilter here markiplier is a
studious man
markiplier tutti-frutti
don't say it back markiplier said
tutti-frutti okay now he's gonna say
what he heard to me markiplier zuv
fruity Tooty not even close but I
already heard that cuz he said out loud
before markiplier is a gorgeous man I
think I like this game you ready mark
here we go
you got it oh love the feeling of mac
and cheese on my face I love the feeling
of mac and cheese on my face I love
shouting I love feeling leather on my
tester ok ok I love feet and leather
testy balls one more time
I love feet and leather testy balls I
love fecal matter I can't help it
I love the feeling of mac and cheese on
my face I love feeling leather on my
come on this B is thick want take a ride
on that deck is it true that cannibals
don't eat clowns because they taste
funny to drool I don't like cannibals
when they're freshly wet move your lips
more I drool on cars and spill my
champagne on life oh my god so long okay
what I heard was I drool on dogs at the
spaceship Museum check out those feet
then I drool on cars and then spilled
champagne on my face what was the
original is it true that cannibals don't
eat clowns because they taste funny
are you a plain bagel because I like you
with nothing on do you like peanut
butter because I jam do you like peanut
butter because I like Vic blueberry this
is gonna be way far off what I heard was
dream on me and then take a picture of
my poop
your lips I'm the only one that has to
read this guy's lips what did you say do
you like peanut butter because I like
big blueberry okay I told you do you
like peanut butter because I jam and the
actual one was are you a plain bagel
because I like you with nothing on and
what did you end up with I like what you
would say back for me I know who on me
okay everybody ready by dancin I'm white
girl wasted I'm a racist reindeer I'm
ready to eat you I'm ready to eat you
I'm pregnant
don't eat Jews that's good advice
I'm ready to eat you I'm a racist
reindeer where I saw pregnant on his
lips and I said I'm white girl wasted
great don't eat Jews okay so thanks so
much for what sorry everyone we offended
and everything okay alright starting
over again also check out the other
thanks so much for watching we really
hope you enjoyed it no matter what so
let us know if you want to see more
challenges in the comments below or
check out my thises channel for another
challenge we just did it was a lot of
fun and it's hopefully funny I have my
good side words right whatever thanks
again for watching thanks Wade and Tyler
for being here and as always we will see
you in the next video bye bye
yeah
[Music]
you